hello hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to
subnautica now I I forgot that I spawned
outside of my pron suit and I just so
happened to be in the dark deep depth of
hell over here and everything is
horrible and I hate everything and every
uh so what I want to do is I need you
back to the surface I want to get to
safety
first and foremost that's more important
than anything that I'm doing right now
but uh I have limited amount of food in
water and actually I have no idea where
I am because things seems so dark and
dreary that I I feel like I'm gonna get
lost in the ether and never be able to
find my home again and that's entirely
possible but I need to get on the way
back up and I need to do that in a hurry
because I'm running out of food and
water as I said before and that means
that death is imminent and I have no
hope and everything is horrible in front
of me so I'm gonna climb my way back out
of here and hopefully get all your Oh
what if someone just say words to me or
am I going out of my goddamn mind
I'm pretty sure I'm going out of my
goddamn mind I'm fairly certain that
that's exactly what's going on here hey
you are horrifying hmm you want to get
ground
you seem beautiful and peaceful but I
know that guy's a dick over there so
maybe it's just your bad neighbor but oh
my God look at you holy [ __ ] what is
with you I mean I'm not one to criticize
you're beautiful in your own way but oh
my god something's going horribly wrong
with your body I don't know how you
survive down here being the way you is
gorgeous admittedly but no just
terrifying
that's right a neum
look at Jane iam the [ __ ] titanium
are you kidding me oh my god that's
[ __ ] titanium holy [ __ ] that's
titanium so there are titanium deposits
out here that I can grind away they've
got two for one okay but that's beside
the point because the blasts have run
out of everything good thing I got big
filtered water I'm a big boy with big
filtered water and big dreams so I'm
gonna be I'm gonna make my way back but
I'm going to go over this way because
there's some bizarre structures over
this way they're that big tree I can't
make my way down there just yet it is
too deep down and I'm not gonna be able
to get there so what I got to do is I
got to make my way I got a swing swung
back up dude
come on hold me hold me baby I gotta
make my way back up this way what is
that I've seen that before
nickel or nickel back nickel or I've
never see even seen nickel ore before
okay so there's sulfur down here in
those nickel or a few new things that I
have not seen before but I'm gonna try
to gather I didn't even notice that one
dip that that inspired by on my way up
ah let us peer myself to death on this
thing huh okay thank you and I wouldn't
be but uh yeah you're a giant bird whoo
okay bye then All Right see ya oh that's
a giant version of the crab things that
are on the island whoa whoa whoa this is
a new area that I have not seen before
holy [ __ ] what the [ __ ] I don't have
time to see this [ __ ] oh my god I'm
gonna eat one of you guys if you come
near me but I'm a little bit desperate
but this is holy [ __ ] that is so weird
what is this place it's just right next
to this I mean this is there's got to be
related some Cyrus from sort of stuff it
and what is this is this one nickel
because it looks different than anything
that I've seen before but it might be
something that I've seen I'm not sure
yeah that's a big deposit of nickel here
I don't know a good that's going to do
me but I can't stay risk out of my suit
that was not English and that was not
good but I can't risk staying out of my
suit too long or else I'm gonna get
killed by the crab squid I've literally
only got one one hit left in me if I can
hit one I'm dead that even means if I
accidentally drift into the into the
brine which is entirely possible but I
don't I don't want to risk it okay
that's all the nickel done I'm gonna get
from that holy Kareem oh Jesus look at
this [ __ ] what the hell it's huge
this [ __ ] ginormous I've never been
down here I didn't even know this
existed it's a whole nother section of
the Lost River there's still brine
that's running through here or sulfur I
think what it actually is it's not brine
brine is just salt water but oh my god
there's so many of those crab things is
there no staring at me Oh more titanium
but I don't need to worry about that
right now
[ __ ] shut up with you okay then I
guess I guess the only way to go is up
but I've never even known this was here
how could I have known yeah I don't have
time to marvel at oh I'm gonna run out
of food at any moment and I'm hoping
that's gonna loop back or at least loop
out of this place maybe I can find
another exit out of here and then I'll
and then I'll be able to go my own way
but it is disturbingly quiet down here
that's another thing that I'm going to
admit about this it is unabashedly quiet
except for a few creatures hither and
thither oh hi
friend you know what goddammit right as
I find himself arisen
ain't that just the [ __ ] right as you
come across and sulfur the [ __ ] war
for a pill okay bye then
nevermind he heard me talking [ __ ] about
him and he decided to bug her on out of
here
good he didn't want me to lay the
smackdown on him if I get warped once
I'm probably gonna die yeesh
whew sorry sorry sorry didn't mean to do
that wookie well apparently I found the
land of milk and honey when it comes to
what I can only seem to be either gold
or copper and then nickel but right now
whoa oh the blood trees or whatever they
were I'm not I'm not entirely sure what
they are exactly but those weird like
all this blood things the weird trees
down in the dark depths okay again it's
either a whale or a man screaming in
pain maybe a man wailing and pain if I
can be so bold but oh oh was that
okay well this is horrifying but I think
this might have been one of the ways I
also came into the Lost River before
they actually built this out
well that crab squid is not looking good
also he's clipping halfway through the
bottom that crab squid wasn't glowing
spots of green before so I'm assuming
that the disease is coming at him I'm
heavy don't even try me buddy whoa whoa
hey come on now you weren't so violent
before you were like my friend oh geez I
imagine the touch of the electrocuting
things ain't gonna be too good for me
okay so I got to get out of here because
I only got 22 percent health left [ __ ]
I'm on the complete wrong side all right
come on time to spoderman out here we
got to go they're going to go and find
out what to do with this sulfur and
nickel first and then we're gonna write
down some names on the lockers and then
we're gonna get out of here but it's
gonna get out of here first alive
preferably oh yeah yeah yeah you know no
you know no you don't know no no no no
no I don't have time for this [ __ ]
er E I usually have a lot of time
allotted in my schedule for just general
[ __ ] er E but I don't have time
right now oh my god where am I oh that's
it sinking into the darkness okay all
right then not sure exactly where I am
or where I ended up but I am a ways away
from where I needed to be but that is
just bizarre
just this session right here that's just
here why and how [ __ ] I should I should
have fallen falling upon a pond please
land on good land that didn't sound good
okay I think we're okay actually I think
we're in a good spot I don't know where
we are cuz it's pitch [ __ ] black but
I think we're okay maybe so I'm right
here I was so stressed for no reason I'm
literally right here how the [ __ ] did I
get what could be question mark
okay alright then I'll eat you thank you
for your contribution so there's an
entrance to the Lost River literally
adjacent to where the life pot is and
the safe shallows that is absurd I
honestly had no idea about that that is
crazy okay but I gotta eat this thing
right now right now and I got a bone
fish - I guess I could eat that but ha
okey and ah Buki okay so now that I've
got back to my thing I have new
materials with which to use but I need
to go all the way back to my base down
below I mean I wish my CMOS could do
what I needed it to do but I think the
next step that I need to do is build a
cyclops
I need a mobile base that can go way
down deep into the depths of the ocean
while also being able to carry with me
my pron suit and I'll get to the lockers
in just a second as soon as I get back
to my base but I'm gonna do some
resource gathering before I do that so
see in a bit how to diamond but really
just mercury or weight have I ever
gotten mercury or wait a minute
cinnabar heat in Oh - to acquire refined
mercury I don't know if I've ever gotten
mercury or before I didn't even know
there was mercury or here oh my god that
have I never gotten mercury or how is
that possible
I have no goddamn idea I guess I've
never just walked down on the bottom
here and I don't even know if I need
mercury but I seem to be gathering a lot
of really rare materials and those are
really rare I'm gonna assume they're
rare because I found them and therefore
that means they are rare to me but
anyway I found him so I'm going to
gather them up as best I can and then
take some where lycium yes please
I mean goddamn know how do I not goddamn
know how could I be so dumb easily
Hurley dearly dearly
diddly diddly deee coming in hot and
heavy Karen I'm asking okay don't know I
know so much dirt on the top of my moon
pool but I ain't gonna question it
all right baba bhot you come me let me
just see oh [ __ ] hi what the [ __ ] oh
okay I'm gonna get in my base before you
have time to [ __ ] me over
Jesus Christ where was that guy just
there
did he just what I didn't even see him
war baby disappeared the [ __ ] was that
about no goddamn idea all right well I
got a lot of rare materials but what the
[ __ ] that guy needs to learn some
goddamn manners okay so I got a lot of
rare materials hopefully doesn't wore me
out of my freakin face I don't think I
have anything that I need for that all
right just gonna start dumping it I'll
coordinate it later once I know that I'm
not gonna die they got plenty of power
[ __ ] that guy [ __ ] that guy is that you
moaning out there huh what are you
moaning down in the deep depth huh
because you have no friends cuz you're
an [ __ ]
I have a funny feeling like that might
be the truth of the matter at least it
got big water here it's big water baby
big water sweet old water I could
possibly need thank you very much water
filtration devices I got my bioreactors
over that's not okay okay I said not has
to do with the weirdness of me deleting
Maya my save game files but God seem to
reduce some lag so I think I could I
think I could deal with that
I think I could deal with a little creep
into my to my goddamn place here but you
know that's okay small price too fast
both okay so I'm going to read some
lockers now I was able to get back to my
face and the warper is being really
weird outside of my base I don't know
why but I seem to be safe in here
ninja cat Caro - said you can dock your
prawn suit in the Cyclops if you make
one and I didn't even know that I could
do that it's going to be a bit of time
before I'm able to make a Cyclops
because I got to go get enamel for
enamel glass I got to go private piece
out of stalkers so that I can do that
then there was Robin Haddix who said you
need to build a second beautiful
so Bumble button mr. Pfister don't have
to bake turns keeping the war pers
company uh I'm starting to think there's
only one war per and it's just following
me around like a douche and I don't even
know why he's doing that but hopefully
he's having fun being an [ __ ] out in
the middle of the goddamn ocean but I
think just one moonpool is enough for
now I got to conserve my resources then
scooter max2 said there's a total of
four precursor bases apparently the
quarantine enforcement platform which is
the big gun
the disease research facility which is
located in the Lost River I imagine if I
go just a little bit deeper and I'm able
to upgrade my mr. Fisher to be able to
go down there I'll be able to find that
one and maybe that one uses the orange
one the orange key that I have but
there's also the precursor power
generator which is located within the
lava castle which is down in the active
lava zone and then finally there is the
primary containment facility which will
eventually house the sea Emperor and is
found in the active lava zone and has
several teleporters as well as a room
with a deactivated warper and there are
other warbirds there and other
aggressive sea life will begin
protecting you and I have no idea what
that means but apparently that's later
on and not implemented in the game just
yet so hopefully we'll be able to see
that but thank you scooting act for that
information now we need to suck we need
to [ __ ] need to fill these things
hang on a second I need to get more get
more [ __ ] into these bad boys I think
there's no other way around it there's
one thing that I have to do above all
else to be able to get farther in this
game and I think number one primarily
above anything else that I could do I
have to make a cyclops I just have to do
it there's no way around it there's no
way I'm going to get farther in the game
unless I right now dedicate myself to
getting the resources necessary to be
able to build that Cyclops and it's not
too hard plastic engine is fine I've got
enough titanium on me right now
to be able to make that plasteel and I
have the lithium the enameled glass it's
a bit of a [ __ ] you just got to get the
teeth from the stalkers lubricant ZZ
advanced wiring kit can be
do that but I got to go back to the
other place to be able to do it I've got
to go back to the dropship and then I
got to go back to Billy Geoff Geoffrey
Billy Sam wise and Marshall by me Aurora
to be able to get that thing actually
built so this is going to take a lot of
work I need to go get the materials
necessary
I've got enough that I'm going to be
able to do it in fact right now I'm just
going to make the titanium necessary to
be able to do that because I've got it
now why not I can do it it's cool and
everything's going to be okay but then I
got to go get the enamel glass and
that's going to take I'm pretty sure you
need to tame some stalkers to be able to
do that even if I don't need to tame
stalkers I'm going to go tame stalkers
and see how that goes for me I honestly
have no idea how that's going to go for
me I'm going to go very bad for me but
we shall see so I'm going to do that
I'll be right back when I get to the
soccer section of this endeavor and
hopefully I won't get my face bitten off
I will be able to get some glass and
some teeth and just generally have a
good time without being terrified and
dead in that order because after I'm
dead - dick that's a few days for the
road yum yum yum yum yum in my tum tum
tum alright let's roll baby
let's roll hopefully we can get around
this barber I should name that warper
imma call you wallaby the warper don't
even think about coming after me you big
old bag of douche Wilfred Wilfred the
warper I could call him Wilfred I'm
going to call him Wilfred the warper Oh
Wilfred the war / how about you go eat
up my bags alright so the recipe to be
able to tame a stopper is to have balls
of steel and then a whole lot of paper
and then he's just kind of like when
it's coming after you you go but not me
ain't this one in it oh my god I don't
wanna die you best kill it instead of a
and then hope for the best
I think that
I'm sure about it but maybe maybe that's
exactly what you're supposed to be doing
and then you don't die and then it
becomes your friend so long as you be
more that's how friendship works you
just keep feeding people till they like
you and then when you stop beating them
they don't like you anymore and they
don't want to be your friend so life
lessons from markiplier keep your
friends fed and then keep them Adam are
in the middle of eggs whatever alright
so step number one to imminent
friendship gather peepers gather all the
people that you could possibly gather it
doesn't matter if they're alive call it
fishing with bubble butt where'd you go
what up are you making a fool of me fine
I'll go find other papers that want to
play with me this is dude sorry now [ __ ]
god damn yours let's hit the paper not
me
[ __ ] you alright got our papers the
whole lot of huh well there's a lot of
papers I just know that stalkers like
peepers is specifically I don't know why
what they like hey you want a peeper hey
you want a peeper yeah I have no idea
how this is gonna go
cool boy you just like deep I don't know
you just like say hi to him you release
it at them where they go they [ __ ]
disappear oh they're over there okay
alright hey you want a peeper I got a
peeper for you that's fresh P P I'll
trade you for that who gonna Bieber hi
[ __ ] you want a peeper huh keep its
people yes [ __ ] top you want a paper
just take it goddamn it
I'll take this oh man that's scary okay
alright
hey friend thanks for bringing me [ __ ]
you want this beeper I'll take that you
want a peeper Oh
eat it wash it oh my god I think it's my
friend god I think it's my friend oh I
think it's my friend I'm not a hundred
percent sure about this because I'm not
very sure about anything but I think
it's my friend you want a paper weight
aluminum eat it yeah yeah eat it eat it
eat it no lost interest god damn it [ __ ]
off I know dammit man life was a lot
harder when I had to worry about oxygen
okay so now that I tamed it what do i do
do I get [ __ ] teeth from it here
daddy
oh yeah I guess letting me scan you yeah
OOP okay good friends with the [ __ ]
stalker I guess hey you want one you
want one buddy I'm gonna watch oh man
you got a farm over here
I'll just take those steal your [ __ ] one
whoa okay
did you drop it - 'th I didn't see a
tooth what happened all my papers what
all bunch of papers I could have thrown
all my papers then it had a bunch
emergency oh [ __ ] I got I guess they're
my friends now
like I think but they didn't give me
what I wanted that's our friendship
works I'll give you some you give me
what I want it's not supposed to be
anyway I think you come back here let me
feed you a soccer it's like you're
afraid of death come on we doing stop
being such a douche I've got nice juicy
peeper for you
whoa [ __ ] goddamn that thing
ah [ __ ] god damn it get the [ __ ] off
my arm stop stop stop stop stop stop
stop
I've got other problems to deal with god
dammit so hard oh my god oh god can't
bring god damn nightmare about you guys
you want to gonna fight my ass
why my ass why my ass bye my ass fight
it bye my ass
don't don't I didn't think I'd have to
shout that in the middle of you got the
emotion why my ass alright so that
didn't quite work out but then again I
always knew that was gonna be trouble
getting the teeth from stalkers has
always been my Achilles heel I don't
know what I'm doing wrong I'll go look
it up but just in case it's changed but
I got them to bite my seam off I got
them to be my friend but then again it
just didn't seem to be working out I
will look into this in the future and
hopefully hopefully I will have an
answer for you very soon but just right
now I just I got a lot of papers in my
pants and I don't have a lot of answers
but by the next episode I will have all
the materials ready and able to build
the Cyclops because it shouldn't be too
hard so long as I'm able to get what I
need to get so I'm going to do exactly
that so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know how I'm doing down
in the comments below thank you one and
all for joining me on this epic
adventure and cheering me on I always
build a schema Oh I will build a Cyclops
from the very next episode and hopefully
get you guys some more progress down in
defeat active lava zone thanks again
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
[Music]